er bekommt zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es über zwei verschiedene themen
zunächst einmal geht es um ein rückblick
auf emotionale künstliche intelligenz
sich nach oben rechts dann im youtube
video den link zu dieser sitzung direkt
rein hier hatte ich mehr wir ein buch
diskutiert von kathrin missel hand mit
dem titel künstliche intelligenz und
empathie ich zitiere auch nochmal zwei
passagen der begriff der emotionalen
künstlichen intelligenz effektiv
computing wurde in den 1990 er jahren zu
der reparationen die emotionale
intelligenz geprägt sie lässt sich
analog zur künstlichen intelligenz als
diejenige disziplin definieren dies mit
der nachbildung oder simulation von
emotionen zu tun hat also damit ob und
wie künstliche systeme emotionen
erkennen
ausdrücken und vielleicht sogar selbst
aufweisen können es geht also um die
frage ob künstliche intelligenz
emotionale muster erkennen kann ob es
emotionen nur simuliert die ki oder
sogar dupliziert oder auch realisiert
das ist die frage ob sie selbst auch
emotionen aufweisen können die frage ist
kann man überhaupt für emotionen
ausdrücken wenn man sie nicht wirklich
hat das ist eine spannende frage sie hat
hier noch ein zitat die notwendigkeit
emotionaler ki erwuchs aus der einsicht
dass emotion eine wichtige rolle für
intelligentes verhalten spielen so gibt
es neurowissenschaftliche evidenzen
dafür dass emotionale störungen aufgrund
einer hirnverletzung zu irrationalem
verhalten führen das kann selbst dann
vorkommen wenn die kognitiven
fähigkeiten im engeren sinn die sich
durch einen klassischen iq-test messen
lassen nicht beeinträchtigt als
emotionen und intelligenz hängen eng
miteinander zusammen und auch deswegen
ist es schon nahe liegend künstliche
intelligenz auch auf emotionen
anzufinden ja jetzt hatten wir hier ein
paar punkte zusammengefasst die ihn noch
einmal präsentieren möchte wir hatten
schon oft von der
mensch-maschine-interaktion gesprochen
das ist häufig so der begriff den man
verbindet wenn man über
die koexistenz oder die interferenz von
künstlicher intelligenz und menschlicher
lebenswillen spricht und auch diese
mensch maschine in der aktion ist auf
emotionale musste erkennung anwendbaren
auch so lässt sich mit verschiedenen
aktionen verstehen im sinne sozialer
künstliche intelligenz das bedeutet
emotionale muster können behält
juristische körperreaktion aber auch nur
ohne zustimmung es seien also ich kann
nur mittels ki emotionen versuchen zu
erkennen anhand von mustern die sich
eben im körper zeigen also bestimmte
körperhaltungen bestimmte bewegungen die
der körper vollzieht aber man kann das
natürlich auch noch mehr ans gehirn
bindung bestimmte botenstoffe bestimmte
signale die da im gehirn vor sich gehen
auch im sinne von mustern verstehen die
sich als emotionen interpretieren lassen
das ist so die frage machte musste
erkennung man muss jedoch betonen dass
wenn wir muster so verstehen sie nicht
mit qualia zu verwechseln sind als die
politischen zuständen
das ist noch mal was ganz anderes wie es
ist angst zu empfinden diesen
subjektiven gehalt den kann künstliche
intelligenz mittels musste erkennung
nicht erkennen sondern eben nur die
äußerungen die muster mäßig erfassbar
sind
körperreaktion oder anorganische
zustände jetzt haben wir zum einen die
frage diskutiert wie emotion erkennbar
sind als muster es kann aber eben auch
roboter oder sonstige maschinen
betreffen die emotionen selbst
manifestieren also die nicht nur muster
erkennen sein selbst musste von
emotionen zeigen und hier stellt sich
jetzt eben die frage ob sie wenn sie
solche emotionen zeigen ob sie die dann
simulieren oder gar duplizieren also
wirklich finden um sie wirklich zu
empfinden bräuchten sie subjektive
zustände anzug waren ja diese emotion
also wirklich angst und nicht nur so tun
als ob
und das ist ein sehr problematischer
punkt es scheint ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich zu sein wir werden
heute aber einen ich sag jetzt mal jungs
philosoph diskutieren nämlich ray
kurzweil der so war es mit sicherheit
nicht für unmöglich halten dürfte auch
wenn er sich in dem text den wir jetzt
heute diskutieren nicht direkt zu dazu
äußert aber mich würde es nicht wundern
wenn das auch für transnistrische
position eine option wäre und das soll
jetzt eben eine kurze einführung noch zu
transfers geben transform an is muss man
spricht von post humanismus also trans
bedeutet eben hinweg überschreiten also
eine tendenz an entwicklung die die
menschliche natur die häufig eben auch
sehr begrenzt ist vor allem kognitiver
sicht überschreitet durch menschenhand
also eine technologie die
transformative ist die disrupt tief ist
so spricht man heute auch sehr gerne von
den neuen technologien revolutionieren
alles das ist ray kurzweil
1948 geboren ich sage ein bisschen was
zu seiner person quelle ist wikipedia er
erfand die kurzwahl rading maschinen die
sehbehinderten erstmals dem zugang zur
normalen text ermöglicht indem es die
trug texte in akustische signale
umwandelt und somit vorlas kurzhals
erfindung gilt bis heute als größter
meilenstein zur gesellschaftlichen
integration sehe hinter dann eben dieser
blindenschrift die schon von dect oder
also hat die blindenschrift sozusagen
auch noch akustisch an ausgegeben und wo
wir schon beim akustischen sind er hat
sich da auch weiter interessiert ja
vielleicht kennen sie die kurzwahl music
systems die
183 könnte dessen synthese die eben in
der lage war natürliche klänge in guter
qualität zu erzeugen
und im jahr 2008 das war mir auch noch
neue gründete er die singularity
university schicker name security ist so
das stichwort mit dem man ihn meistens
verbindet die security university die
möchte ich eine kurze vorstellen
aber da möchte ich zunächst noch ein
zitat lesen dass überhaupt die
singularität ist das sollte man nämlich
auch noch kurz erwähnen wort ist
security in the future patrick döring
witches of technological change ubisoft
jetzt impact so der university of the
european ist ob des eher pop wird ins
formel concept and rely on to give me
your life von business models of your
life including der 14 also das ist das
säkuläre dass es eben alles betrifft die
distribution betrifft alles
und sie
führt dazu dass unsere biologische
begrenzt begrenzung überwunden wird das
ist dieses buch des security ist mir
das ist dieses titelbild von diesem buch
und hier sieht man einen von vielen
grafiken die kurz vor sehr gerne
verwendet um seine these der
singularität zu veranschaulichen
es geht letztendlich immer um selbe
prinzip um exponentielles wachstum immer
hier auf der x-achse ist dass die zeit
man zieht hier es hat stark spekulativen
charakter weil sich nicht davor scheut
bis ins jahr 2100 zu extrapolieren
und das ist eben immer der punkt bei
exponentiellen wachstum am anfang steigt
noch nicht so und irgendwann dann später
in der zukunft soll es nach
exponentiellen wachstum sehr sehr stark
steigen
das ist natürlich immer das problem
leben wir denn noch können wir das
verifizieren da kann immer sagen ja es
ist exponentielles wachstum noch ist es
sehr gering aber schau mal die 10 20
jahren also das ist so ein problem das
wir auch noch diskutieren werden
jedenfalls die singularität ist dann
erreicht wenn es so steige ansteigt
diese leistungsfähigkeit hier die
kalkulations president pro 1 dollar habe
also auch immer brück gebunden finanzen
und auch ökonomische verhältnisse die
exponentielle leistung wird zunehmend
dass irgendwann ein zustand erreicht
wird wo eben was neues energie hat auch
der begriff dm ergänzt wird sehr häufig
von kurzweil und anderen
traditionalisten und trans am ist im
verwendet jetzt hatte ich schon gesagt
ich möchte kurz security university
vorstellen so sieht das logo aus und das
ist so die das motto axxelerate change
exkremente technologies angel
fundamental sei der
optimismus in government is computing
power and connectivity xplode denn der
koste christoph then i want to be
changemaker and
security wie fonds und die stickies der
convergence and work to open your mind
to the possibility der unlock hier haben
wir also wieder die schlüsselbegriffe
exponentielles wachstum
dies funktion auch hier passt
explodieren als hat eine ganz starke ja
energis tische mit hervor rückt die hier
verwendet wird immer eben auch auf die
technologie bezogen aber auch im bezug
auf die gesellschaft die ebendies rupp
tief betroffen ist das heißt nicht nur
einzeln bereits und generell eben auch
durch die technologie verändert wird und
zwar tief greifende jetzt möchte ich
noch kurz auf ein buch gehen was heute
in der heutigen sitzung im zentrum
stehen soll das steht man nur so ein
bisschen schatten von seinem buch
singularität nähe das heißt jetzt die
age of spirit to machine and computer
sexy human intelligence hier sehen wir
jetzt schon dass er von spiritual
spricht also geistige maschine und das
scheint doch auch zu implizieren dass so
etwas wie subjektivität oder auch qualia
oder auch emotionalität für maschinen
nicht undenkbar ist
und aus diesem buch wollen wir dann ein
paar passagen des kopieren und zwar
anhand folgender leitfragen wir machen
wir drei leitfrage was versteht kurzweil
und
technologie das müssen wir auch immer
diskutieren das ist ja der
schlüsselbegriff tja aber keineswegs so
klar ist zweite frage was sind kurzhals
argumente dass eine postfeministische
theorie und sind sie nur spekulativ und
das ist eben auch die dritte frage damit
zusammen inwiefern ist kurzhals
transform an ismus philosophisch
überzeugend inwiefern problematisch ich
glaube wir kommen um kurzwellen nicht
rum weil er so sagen der inbegriff
derjenigen denkerin und denke da stellt
die technologie extrem ernst nehmen und
die eben auch sich auf die neueste
entwicklung von künstlichen pflegenden
berufen kann wenn eben ein spiel wie
alpha go den besten schauspieler bis sie
dann fühlen sich natürlich dran zu
managen und ranglisten bestätigt in
ihren annahmen das müssen wir natürlich
philosophisch diskutieren und darum
sollst in der heutigen sitzung gehen